vous pensiez que jamais de votre vivant
vous n'assisterez à la fin de la série
quotidienne les feux de l'amour
ah oui il faut dire qu'avec ses 48
saison et c'est 11920 épisodes diffusés
à la télé ce feuilleton devenu culte
fait partie de nos vies à tous depuis
1989 ce feuilleton fait en france les
beaux jours de tf1 qui diffuse chaque
jour à 11h un nouvel épisode il est de
cette série ils en ont de la chance mais
pour la toute première fois ce rendez
vous culte dans les ehpad va connaître
un bouleversement en effet en raison de
la pandémie la chaîne cbs productrice du
programme a décidé de suspendre les
tournages depuis le 17 mars dernier suis
désolé c'est pas ma faute
un arrêt de l'activité qui pourrait
avoir une conséquence sur la diffusion
dans notre pays
mais si la france a deux ans de retard
sur la diffusion des épisodes américain
ce n'est pas l'arrêt de ses tournages
qui pourrait empêcher la diffusion
d'épisodes inédits mais le problème du
doublage en effet les doubleurs de la
série sont dans l'impossibilité de
réaliser la traduction des nouveaux
épisodes
une première les épisodes inédits
pourraient donc très rapidement arriver
à terme je sais que tu es déçu et confus
je suis désolé si c'est moi qui t'ai mis
dans cet état
même constat du côté de plus belle la
vie sur france 3 qui là encore à cause
du coronavirus a dû mettre à terme au
tournage il ya plusieurs semaines de ça
à compter du 4 mai prochain france 3
sera désormais contrainte de diffuser
des rediffusions des meilleurs moments
de son feuilleton quotidien
quand vous parlez messieurs le salaire
passionnant une diffusion qui devrait se
poursuivre jusqu'à la reprise des
tournages alors plus belle la vie les
feux de l'amour c'est la fin des séries
les plus cultes vont elles vous manqué
alors ouais ça ça c'est un truc que
c'est un truc de ouf quand même non mais
franchement c'est que ces deux faits
depuis 73 que les feux de l'amour ne se
sont jamais arrêtés
et ouais voilà alors je vous dis les
galères qu'il ya pour les reprises de
tournage des rassemblements de plus de
10 personnes
que ce soit dans les espaces publics ou
privés seront interdits dès le 11 mai
jusqu'à nouvel ordre donc forcément pour
tourner une scène il ya beaucoup plus de
monde donc forcément pour les fictions
c'est catastrophique on a également a
priori de déconfinement devrait se faire
en plusieurs étapes
d'un côté des départements seront
classés vert et bénéficieront d'un
déconfinement plus souple de l'autre des
départements en rouge avec des mesures
plus strictes en fonction de l'évolution
des cas yao koffi 19 donc forcément
marseille alors il paraît qu'à marseille
pour plus belle la vie
il paraît qu'ils vont être ouverts un
parent à qui de marseille c'est ce qu'on
entend dire on aura tout ça tout à
l'heure on va vous en parler bien
entendu mais c'est vrai voilà ça pose
problème
est-ce que ça va vous manquer est ce que
vous comprenez où est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils doivent trouver des solutions
voilà on parle bien sûr médias vous
savez aussi on sait que vous aimez quand
on parle médias par exemple jean luc
azoulay lui le producteur des mystères
de l'amour qui reprendra ses tournages
le 12 mai mais lui il est toujours très
inventif il a trouvé un moyen il et il
est excellent il va essayer de trouver
un moyen de tourner avec moins de 10
personnes
je connais jean lui que c'est un c'est
un génie oui
boni ribéry c'est très compliqué moi à
titre personnel je regarde pas ces
feuilletons mais je vois tous les
parents ma grand-mère qui adorait les
labourés malheureusement bel adoré ça et
toujours voir des équipes techniques sur
le ko et des comédiens sourds car c'est
vraiment la peine moi par exemple
contrarie les ingénieurs qui sont au
cinéma
tout est arrêté c'est un drame ils
reçoivent l'as pas encore reçu une
annulation de tournage parce que sur les
scenarii par exemple il ya une scène
dans un couloir
comment tourner dans un couloir de
comédiens de techniciens et c'est
vraiment ça devient très très compliqué
même si on essaie d'adapter les plantes
tournage les séquences pour essayer de
limiter les plans etc
c'est c'est vraiment ubuesque ils ne
savent plus comment faire
ça va réellement commencer à poser des
problèmes vraiment alors oui alors
qu'arnaud enrôler yakin kiwi selon le
magazine capital les bouches-du-rhône
donc marseille seront en zone rouge
donc on verra ça on sera bientôt à tommy
alors je vais vous dire il ya un petit
truc là dessus je vais pas soulevé la
polémique mais je vais vous dire la
rumeur qui tourne autour de ça je vous
en parlerai tout à l'heure je pense que
ça va mettre au nez en run je crois que
gilles est au courant de cette rumeur un
moment j'ai dit non on en parlera tout à
l'heure tu y as re juste sur les
feuilletons il ya notre ami et notre
collègue clément guérin qui nous dit
c'est un casse tête pour la prod carling
visé et embrassades seront interdits
dans plus belle la vie et les intrigues
sentimentales rythme des feuilletons
comme plus belle la vie
a priori le tournage ne reprendra pas
avant l'été est toujours sans les
comédiens les plus âgées et vulnérables
qui resteront chez eux
surtout que deux comédiennes de plus
belle la vie on tue le coc vidait ça
c'est une très bonne info de clément
guérin qui a toujours des bonnes infos
clément c'est incroyable cette histoire
hein donc c'est vrai qu'on n'y a pas
pensé mais là j'aimerais que les baisers
dans les séries et tous avaient atteint
savez une galère saint gilles alors plus
belle la vie
je suis persuadé qu'ils sont inventifs
et qu'on me colle à l'actualité de notre
vie même hélas une actualité dramatique
je pense qu'ils vont savoir se
réinventer peut-être tourné différemment
réduire les effectifs
mais ça va aller pour des séries
américaines comme les feux de l'amour je
vous le dis très franchement je sais que
des gens regardent sans faire 11920
épisode
pour moi c'est fini il faut arrêter
voilà c'est une bonne occasion de couper
tout ça et dans ces roches chaudes de
faire autre chose
ayez gens adorent les gens adorent oui
benjamin castaldi
honnêtement je moi je pense évidemment
aux comédiens je pense à tous et
techniciens c'est ce que vit le monde du
spectacle je vous le dis c'est une
catastrophe dans le monde entier c'est
pas qu'en france et le monde entier
alors je ne t'aime pas les feux de
l'amour tu peux pas penser ça fait
bouffer je pense
dix mille personnes et de l'amoureux à
los angeles c'est une industrie et des
cd studio etc
moi je suis très inquiet pour deux pour
les comédiens et pour tous les gens du
spectacle
effectivement je vous le dis ils vont
être ceux qui vont payer je crois le
plus lourd tribut dans cette histoire
parce que effectivement les couvertures
on les connaît ils sont elles sont pas
terribles pour les pourvois là les
habitants c'est toujours compliqué moi
j'ai mon père
les punks évidemment très très très très
inquiet que ça on a perdu on n'a pas
entendu vous pratiquez où on papa mais
bien sûr et empire qu'on en moi oui
voilà et vous voilà il ya plein de gens
qui l'appelle pour pour la cité à voile
a haussé le ton et expliquer aux gens
combien ça va être compliqué pour les
théâtres privés etc
voilà donc c'est vrai moi je suis je
suis de tout coeur avec tout ce métier
là et pour cause mais c'est vrai que je
j'entends des choses et j'ai eu des gens
au téléphone et la situation allait
dramatique alors les dramatiques pour
beaucoup beaucoup de gens évidemment je
vois là je veux pas des gens à part mais
c'est vrai que dans ce métier là ça va
être très compliqué je vous le dis
bonsoir rené bonsoir velay rené pagis
gyan un petit peu à la fin de ce qu'a
dit b jamais c'est que il faut passer
outre en j'aime j'aime pas parce que moi
je veux bien mais je m'appuie belle la
vie j'aime pas mais dans une situation
comme on dit il ya tous ces emplois qui
s'écoule bien une économie monstrueux et
qui se trouve déjà que dix ans à la rue
et que mais parce que complet les
artistes comme on appelait les commerces
ceux qui ne vont pas ouvrir tous ceux
qui s'estiment de ça après qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous aimez vous n'aimez
pas c'est ça le talent de saint côme
nibali sa mère et sa grand voile à
regarder et il faut passer outre le
j'aime ou j'aime pas eu
il faut sort de côte du du moine de
québec à la rue nation ne soit retiré
tout cas merci merci on est bon soir
avoue girondine ouais ouais c'est vrai
que je penserai à ma grand mère parce
que déjà qu'elle est confiné tout seul
mais depuis le début du confinement elle
avait effectivement ces séries c'était
les chiffres des grands de parenthèse
ramené dans sa journée c'était son
rendez vous effectivement pour elle
c'est un déchirement relative bien sûr
mais c'est voilà elle se dit que
vraiment plus rien ne va quoi elle se
sent encore plus seul et encore plus
isolé est effectivement je pense que ça
va être très graves comme l'a dit
benjamin comme l'a dit rené c'est à dire
qu'il ya une diète des jeux inédits
il ya une diète des fictions et à dire
que de la même manière que le
confinement vous habite nous a donné
enfin en tout cas nous a obligés à
penser la télé différemment comme vous
le faites tous les soirs je pense que le
déconfinement va aussi nous obliger à
penser la télé différemment les séries
différemment j'ai vu que par exemple le
tournage des tuche 4 avec jean paul
rouve
il avait il était en tournage ils ont dû
tout réécrire parce qu'il ya plein de
scènes qui ne peuvent plus être fait
comme ça parce qu'il y avait plein de
figurants donc en fait il va falloir
réadapter les scénarios les fictions
tout tout tout le barnum des tournages à
la nouvelle situation sanitaire
bien oui valérie avec une donnée
supplémentaire ces campus maintenant les
assurances sont extrêmement frileuses
parce qu'elles ne veulent pas vous
entend plus valérie complet vous valérie
on vous entend pas du tout ma chérie
donc je vais expliquer auront parlé des
assurances il ya un autre problème à
résoudre c'est celui des assurances bien
entendu puisque le 20 avril dernier une
vingtaine de producteurs ont écrit au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
pour demander à ce que les tournages
soient impérativement assurer contre les
risques d'arrêt ou de suspension liée
aux coronavirus est pour le moment les
compagnies d'assurance ne vole pas
prendre de rides donc dans ces
conditions les séries peuvent pas
reprendre leurs tournages après long
mais ça va être compliqué parce que ça
peut être vraiment des milliers et des
milliers d'euros engagés raymond temps
c'est même celui de bougies un mari des
milliards oui en tout huit morts oui moi
c'est moi ça me chante pas ça me fera
pas une grosse perte les feux de l'amour
moi je fais partie des gens qui
travaillent à l'heure où ça passe donc
je m'en fous complètement
plus belle la vie le soir à l'heure où
ça passe c'est pas le programme que je
regarde quand je suis devant la télé à
ce temps là donc je m'en fous
complètement aussi mais c'est vrai que
j'ai une pensée pour tous les
techniciens comme comme l'audi les
camarades parce que c'est quand même 250
mille emplois c'est je pense 50
milliards et ils payent leurs impôts
comme tout le monde et pourtant eux
c'est les oublier ils sont pas les même
statut que les autres
donc c'est vrai que j'ai une pensée pour
eux sont rares voire les a bien sûr je
suis les horizons qui se font doubler la
collection
il en est je vais créer monte carlo
tevez aurait son suspens plateau ne pas
faire encore ce que fait nagui et qui
bat des records avec des blés stoxx bien
cher avec celle avec des rediffusions
nous il fait deux fois le record des
autres c'est incroyable je préfère
encore ce qu'on fait nous je préfère
encore ce que fait lignac plutôt d
émission en plateau
donc il faudra revoir mais après pour
finir ça va commencer compliqué
d'expliquer que tu peux pas aller
tourner une série dans un pavillon ou
dans un jardin et que les enfants
peuvent retourner à l'état quantique à
moment donné ça nous dit la tête qui on
peut aller dans le métro mais on peut
pas faire une série télé les gars vous
êtes en train de nous rendre dingue
dites nous ce qui se passe dit nous les
choses c'est pas possible ça rêvons il
est génial alors les séries il ya malins
qui dit value bug ya une manuelle qui
lui dit opus tout pour nous mettre zéro
avant plus belle la vie c'est bien relou
on connaît des épisodes parker à force
est vrai que rho aux oraux ou non peu
plus sur france 3 ils ont dû où ils ont
trois épisodes qui font tourner c'est
toujours les mêmes on n'en peut plus oui
oui rené oui et façonnent mois des
soirées que ce soit ce qu'on me dit
c'est qu'on vient sur oman s'est créé du
jeu et l'après la presse l'économie
mondiale va s'effondrer
on a patiné chier parce que on va parler
chaque pas d'une corporation
on pourra dire il ya des milliers
d'emplois qui tombe une autre compassion
des milliers d'emplois on va vivre une
crise mondiale peut découler l'économie
mondiale et qui va s'effondrer et on
n'est pas prêt de s'en relever
alors il va falloir arrêter de se faire
des petits bobos de signer là l'enfant
reprenne avant le corps ce problème
parce qu'on n'est pas sorti de la merde
d'accord va en tout cas merci pour ce
message d'espoir renaît c'est important
pour les gens qui n'ont qu'un train
bondé rebooster un peu l'école ça ça
fait du bien ça fait du bien ça en douce
tout ça il va falloir aider les
intermittents les chéris après
confinement et on essaiera de faire le
maximum
oui il va casser question juste juste
posé juste pour préciser pour les pour
les gens qui traînent dans ce spectacle
il n'y a pas de chômage partiel de 84%
80% et l'aja 2-0 et salace et ça va et
ça pour les deux cent cinquante mille
personnes
on y voit quand on perd quand on perd
des dates de spectacles des datas
l'enserré djinnit s'est accrue ouais ben
si il ya quelqu'un qui nous dit
comment tu peux dire que c'est difficile
pour ton père benjamin tu te foute qu'il
gagne très bien sa vie on ne peut rien
si la claque et tout son fric qu'est ce
qui te répond à ses attentes à quoi
alors je n'aurais même pas répondre
parce que c'est à dire où s'arrête ginon
mais je vais c'est malin je vais
répondre en plus le père de benjamin
c'est vrai qu'il a essayé de se
débrouiller toute sa vie mais benjamin
je crois que ton père on va pas se
nommer il n'a jamais roulé sur l'or je
pensais arrêter de penser sur 100
comédie je veux vraiment sur ce comédien
vous en avez cinq qui gagnent très bien
leur vie
non mais quoi c'est bien le sait c'est
que non mais c'est très très bien j'en
parle parle de 1 million de millions
extra plus normé sciences ou quoi tu
étais sa zone avaient ces faux voilà
après vous en avez une petite vingtaine
qui gagnent correctement leur vie c'est
à dire que ce sont des cadres supérieurs
on va dire voilà des gens qui gagnent
bien leur vie
après vous avez dansé plus que le
qualifiant les vins non non non des
galeristes vous dise éducazoo à sa
décision qui travaillent bosse bien très
bien même très bien
oui d'accord et après laure est à dire
en gros 60%
ils n'arrivent pas à boucler les fins de
mois gueye - parfois moins que le smic
alors c'est un choix voulez venir c'est
un choix ils ont voulu faire comédiens
d'accord oui je sais mais arrêtez de
penser que tous les gens qui sont devant
les caméras sont blindées ou derrière
son blindé il ya beaucoup de gens qui
gagnent pas forcément des tonnes et des
milliers et des tonnes d'argent c'est
pas vrai c'est sûr qu'ils ont une
passion qui au fond ça pas vraiment par
passion et voilà et parfois ça
fonctionne ça marche ce sont des stars
mais il ya pour une star il ya dix mille
personnes qui n'ont pas à manger à la
fin du mois bon voilà oui j'ai attendu
six mois j'en ai fini fini voilà c'est
tout moi je suis moi j'ai vu mon père je
veux pas faire pleurer dans les
chaumières mon père quand il avait 24
ans qui m'avait tout petit peu pas
m'emmener à droite à gauche parce qu'il
a eu il est pas d'oreilles et ses
parents n'en avait pas non plus donc
voilà il habite beaucoup de beaucoup de
temps à se faire connaître a gagné un
peu d'un peu d'argent et croyez moi il
n'a jamais gagné des montagnes star loin
de là loin de là